[Music]
my second time in Singapore I really
like it here I think there's a huge
diversity of people and it just makes it
really really fun everybody that I talk
to seems to be doing three different
things with food and with just kind of
goes all over the place I am Tim this is
me I'm an avid tooth brush ax and you
might know me from some of my online
things you might have seen me from some
of the the previous events today so I'm
a tinkerer tuner tempura I just like to
make stuff I'm not really big on titles
but I'm an engineer I guess it had a bit
of a design or a bit of everything
really like all of us yeah so you might
have seen me on the first day where we
we won the family feud the JavaScript
family feud you might have noticed that
our team got absolutely no correct
technical questions but we were very
very good at guessing how much coffee
everybody drinks you might have seen me
ad code in the dark which was really
awesome on a couple of nights ago was
really fun I've never actually seen that
before people kind of coding without
being able to look look at what they're
making and and just see the results it
was really really fun event with Justin
organizing that and as they are standing
it as an as an emcee yeah maybe you know
me from some of my online things or
maybe you can get to know me through
these online things I was emceeing at
the CSS comfy you just late last year
and I kind of released a bunch of things
just for for a kind of potty pack
obnoxious that CSS is an example of one
of these I kind of wanted to do a take
on animate CSS but I wanted to do kind
of obnoxious animations obnoxious
animations are really really fun to make
they kind of go really big they kind of
get up in your face
and this is really what you need to grab
the attention of your users for all of
your websites
you know it's phenomenal I made this
website off four or five years ago the
useless web it you will click on this
please button and it will take you to
other kind of random websites that are
very weird and Audion line eel Slough is
an example of something like that
this whole website just exists so you
can kind of slap people with eels is
phenomenal who made that it doesn't make
any sense this is a library that I made
a couple of years ago
elevator jsut kind of scroll to the bone
on the page and there's one of those
back to the top buttons that everybody
always kind of sees
[Music]
provides you a nice enjoyable smooth
scrolling to the top experience last
year again CSS come for I put out smell
vodka I opened up the Helvetica font
file in font foregin and messed around
with all the kerning and made it really
ugly and messy and you can install it on
your friend's machine and it kind of
replaces the whole system Helvetica font
and it's just just weird enough that you
know if I put her on my mom's computer
she thinks that it's weird but she lives
with it and you have you know it's a
frustrating thing you know later on
someone will say all these websites have
looked really weird lately
oh whoops forgot to put forgot that I
put that on there again I released this
office simulator slack while we had a
great talk up here about buds before
which was really cool this slack ball
kind of simulates the mundane office
messages that you get every now and then
you know whoever left yoga in the fridge
got to get it out of there and and and
all that kind of business don't forget
you know the passive-aggressive don't
forget our dynamics lunch later on today
that's office life maybe you've seen
some of my more serious things these get
hub corners are all around the internet
you kind of hover the thing and it gives
you a little wave it's an i7 that was
regular for Cle buttons there's a fun
little project to make because you kind
of see it all over the place maybe
you've seen my LinkedIn profile pull of
dog pictures if you don't you can
connect with me on LinkedIn and you can
have dog pictures daily it's really
really fun look at these top top notch
analytics over here yeah so that's so
that's me if you've ever seen me speak
before you're gonna kind of realize that
this this talk topic is the same talk
that I've been doing for a while now and
I just thought I would just go straight
up front and tell you what the goals are
and what I want one of the point that I
want to make to everybody before we even
go and that's to kind of look at what
inspires you and and look at what gets
you excited and and not just kind of on
a web perspective but on a kind of much
grander scale I want you to realize that
you can kind of follow your feelings
with your ideas and you can chase them
down to the end and you can see where it
takes you
and it doesn't have to be big it doesn't
have to be small you can just kind of
get into it
I want you to kind of embrace the weird
a little bit you know just because
you're building something that nobody
else can use doesn't mean you should
stop building it because it is gonna be
a quirky thing and you're gonna learn a
lot along the way it's gonna be really
really fun and so the best way that I've
learned to do that is just by showing
you a few of my own kind of journeys in
my own explorations and where I went
with them and what ideas I had and the
kind of outcome and then hopefully you
can kind of see that and go well that's
really doable that's a that's something
that I can totally totally get into so
let's do that yeah recently I was at my
mom's house in Australia we're right in
the country beautiful place sugar cane
fields everywhere beautiful sunsets and
I was sitting in the lounge room the
lounge rooms just got kind of a big
comfortable couch lots of lots of
windows a small TV and a DVD player and
I found myself really really really
entranced and and I kind of snapped out
of it a little bit and I thought what
what was that what was just happening
and I was looking at oh these are the
movies that we have we've got very
Australian selection I was looking at
this on the screen DVD video and I
imagine probably everybody's seen this
and the DVD video if you if you haven't
seen what it does it does this it
bounces around the screen it's a square
box let's look at that first bounce
again once more for those in the back
this is where it destroys my hopes and
this is where it destroys my dreams we
can assume really that if I hate is
gonna hate and a potato's gonna - Tate
then a DVD logo will never hit the
corner of the screen and it's so
frustrating because you kind of lock
onto it and you watch it and you watch
it you watch it and I talked to a ton of
people about this and it's just I don't
know what it is some kind of odd human
nature that you want it to bounce splat
bang in the corner and I kind of thought
to myself what is actually happening
here let's look at the math let's kind
of try to understand it a little bit
let's put our scientific or hats on so I
started to try to dig into you know into
this world
and I found this fantastic blog online
called the lost math lessons is one of
those nice little Nishi internet things
it's this high school teacher who kind
of comes up with weird ideas from math
lessons and and writes about them and
kind of explains the math and I don't
think anybody kind of explained the math
behind this better than him so I thought
I'd put it up here so here you would
imagine that that square is a logo or
maybe a 1 pixel by one pixel logo and
it's 16 across and it's 10 high and we
can kind of see the numbers here and we
can kind of draw some conclusions so it
seems to be bouncing on the bottom and
the top every nine squares every nine
moves and it seems to be bouncing on the
sides every 15 and so we have 16 and 10
but if you minus one for the space that
the logo actually is you kind of get
that you get those numbers 9 and 15 and
the total moves it takes to hit onto the
corner is 45 which is actually the
lowest common multiple of 9 and 15 and
so that kind of fits into this formula
the steps to take to the steps that it
takes to get to the corner is the lowest
common multiple of the width of the
screen minus the width of the logo and
the height of the screen and the height
of the logo and yeah we just kind of
keep going with this math just just for
the sake of it if you put velocity is
its velocity equals distance over time
into that and kind of mix it around a
little bit you get this I won't go too
much but the time that it takes equals
the horizontal time which is the time
that a logo takes to hit one side to the
other side times the lowest common
multiple of the things before divided by
the width minus the logo with its top
stuff with the math I'm gonna start with
the math but using that I could then
calculate how long is it actually going
to take how long am I gonna have to sit
here until I get the corner hit that I
want it's like a drug and then I built
like let me like build a little demo
around here so I can look at the
different numbers and it's it's kind of
random because lowest common multiples
work that way so that you'll get some
numbers they're really really small you
know a hundred and 122 seconds that's
fantastic but then you get some that are
you know 3,000 seconds and it's just the
kind of depth and dynamics of the screen
3500 it's like what 50 minutes or
something like that there's our agreed
and so I thought well I've come this far
I can't stop what can I do about this
how can we fix this problem it's such a
it's such a huge thing as plaguing
society and of course the initial
reaction would be ah let me just speed
up Logan let's just walk into the lounge
room oh yeah there it is get that fix
this was the second second solution
that's kind of a COMSAT aspiring
satisfying result you think that's one
good let's get this going on just hook
it into my veins you know but after
making these little demos I kind of had
to think to myself and this is the
saying that I'm gonna use at what point
am I just eating ass last time I was in
Singapore I went to a cocktail bar with
Thomas and they had this ant cocktail
and they got ants and they put him on a
leaf and then they put him in liquid
nitrogen or something like that and then
you kind of eat the ants and drink the
drink and I was definitely intrigued I
had to taste the ant cocktail but after
a while I was kind of thinking this is
just eating ants this I know what adds
taste like now this is just eating ants
and these demos are a little bit like
that you know I'm getting a little bit
of satisfaction here but I'm not getting
the satisfaction that I would get if it
bounced lowly into the corner so I do
some drew some very technical graphs
here actually did these yesterday
there's happiness and it's overtime and
this is the one where it just hits the
corner all the time you get a plain base
level of happiness but this is the
regular experience in my lounge room as
I watch my happiness level goes down and
down and down and down and down and down
and down until I'm rock-bottom you know
really depressed and then hits the
corner bounces in the other direction
adrenaline everything goes go straight
up and so this is the wasted time in
this in this algorithm and it's just
crazy to think like how much how much
human time really goes into this what's
going on can I come up with another
solution can I come up with a better
solution
can I just take that time out of it and
just jump straight up into the happiness
and you're like stuff no this is how
intelligent a eyes are made they're
gonna take over the world you know it
starts with the screensaver and then it
is Skynet but we're not stopping we're
gonna keep going so I yeah so I built
the intelligent screensaver so it
bounces around as normal but then after
a certain amount of time it hits a point
it hits it goes super saiyan you know it
goes whoa wait a second what's going on
it puts a cost out where where am i
aiming to go ooh that's close what if
the angle is really small just small
enough that a human wouldn't notice it
yeah let me just redirect let me refocus
on that bingo we're in you hit the
corner we got the happiness we can just
we can just go we can move on with our
lives I can go outside again Wow what
that was so weird but this is this is
exactly what I'm kind of talking about
today is this is a journey this is a
something that we've kind of gone on
I've started with something and I've
gone somewhere weird with it in my own
time in the afternoon a couple of
afternoons actually without any stress
without any real goals but at the end of
the day you can kind of say whoa look at
what we made here I made four demos Java
Script canvas html5 I did enough
research and enough kind of things here
for a small lightning talk or a big talk
in front of everybody played with the
requestanimationframe that Jake was
talking about played with cubic and
quadratic Bezier to do these curves I
had to look that up I had to understand
how that stuff worked a lot of line
intersection mouth kind of goes into the
into the one that actually focuses you
know if the first angle isn't immediate
then we're gonna have to see when it
does kind of land closer to the thing
and that's a lot that's a lot for a
square bouncing around the screen and
that's a lot of information that I'm
gonna retain and then I'm gonna have at
hand in any other kind of situation and
yeah that's that's what I'm kind of
talking about I also worked on a white
paper I'm kind of submitting it around
trying to try to stir people up I've
called it the screen Savior and it's a
yeah a whole writing about reducing the
overall time wasted you know it's that
white paper guff that they give you I
just want the information but no Julius
time
oops skipping some head yeah but that's
it that's a lot to produce just from
such a such a small little experiment I
think about balance a lot and whenever
whenever we talk about balance in tech I
think everybody immediately your head
will jump to the work-life balance which
of course we know is important then when
your balance is off you get you get
exhausted you get irritated you get
frustrated you get so so tired and it's
just hugely detrimental to your life of
course but the balance that I think
about a little bit more is the kind of
inter project balance so if we took that
red line there and expanded it and
looked at the balance within that this
is the this is the area that I find
really interesting in tech I I like to
use these kind of two terms on my scales
practice which would be oh you know
building Kings with the knowledge that
you have and then creativity is the part
where you're exploring different
solutions and you're trying to find
different ways to solve these problems
you're using different technologies
you're doing some research that's the
kind of creative side of it and I think
when this gets overflown and and it just
becomes maybe all practice you just come
in today as like oh what am i building
this is what they told me to build and
you don't have the creativity you get a
same kind of similar burnout and I think
when you're talking to somebody and they
get all antsy and gruff about what
framework you're using oh this isn't
good this isn't the best these are the
kind of people that tend to have a
little bit of a offset balance on that
on the inside yeah I also think a lot
about this guy gets electric shock III
talk a lot I think a lot about where my
mind is going when I'm doing certain
things I sometimes find what I'm doing a
project my brain is thinking oh here's
another thing that I want to do here's
another thing that I want to do here's
another thing that I want to do and you
kind of got I better rein myself in and
I similar that similarly down that vein
I have a little bit of a hard time kind
of meditating and having like a clear a
clear mind so I thought oh I'll go on
another journey I'll build something
else I'll do some experimentation and
I'll use myself as the guinea pig and
the the kind of thoughts and ideas that
were coming into my head of what project
should I even do in the first place you
know a lot of people have trouble just
taking that initial step oh I don't have
any ideas but there's so much stuff you
know kind of touched on this yesterday
when she said there's so much more
inspiration than just online you know
don't look at don't look at other
websites so yeah I was kind of looking
at myself I was thinking about menial
tasks I was thinking about things like
the screen saver but and then the other
the other kind of dimension that I
wanted in this project was what are
things that I find captivating and of
course that menial tasks captivating the
there kind of opposites but can I
include them into the same in the same
project because that's what meditation
seems like to me really people just kind
of zone out into a special place and
they want it they need it it's
captivating to them they have benefits
to it but also they're kind of not doing
anything
and so yeah I kind of went out and
looked in search for in search for this
project and I just thought I'd mentioned
briefly this kind of streetlight effect
the people sometimes get when they're
searching in for new projects the
streetlight effect is this kind of idea
about a bias that humans have where the
way that it's usually told is this drunk
guy is kind of lost his keys on the
ground and he's searching around trying
to find him searching around trying to
find him and a police officer comes and
he goes I just lost my keys and the
police officer was kind of looking
around as well and they can't find him
and he goes are you sure you lost him
here and he goes oh no no I'm just
searching under the streetlight because
it's the easiest area to look whereas in
reality I think there's so much more out
there and in the world rather than just
kind of going straight to the internet
for your ideas so I was just looking at
everyday life menial but captivating
brushing your teeth I brush my teeth
every day twice a day and it's kind of
weirdly I'm into it you know I want to
do it
wake up you EU breakfast knives and
forks you switch the light on and so I
thought I'd run with this idea of
switches switching things on you know
that's a part of meditation in the first
place really you don't know you want to
kind of switch on by switching off so I
looked online I found a few nice kind of
designs code pen was a really good
resource switches
I thought have I done anything with
switches before oh yeah I've done a
couple of projects I built this
programming simulator that's very very
accurate everyone can play at home
I I did another one a trying to fall
asleep simulator what what did I do that
today how much if I go to sleep right
now I'm gonna be like I was so down five
years ago you know this is the the going
to sleep cycle in my head I've done
things with switches before I've kind of
played with them what would happen if I
put a ton of switches on on the screen
and so that's what I thought I would do
I would just kind of make a screen of
switches oh this is kind of nice like
going green
oh maybe I'll go down here a little bit
it's weird it's captivating I've started
now I gotta finish
oh I filled in this whole square I'm
gonna gonna make everyone stay until I
originally I had a hundred on here but I
thought I'd cut it down to the top oh
it's weird like you see that reaction Oh
what you know this this idea totally
hooked onto me now the idea of focusing
on something like switches yeah that
just did it so I figured oh I'm just
gonna build a bunch of game similar to
the switches similar to the switches
screen what other things are captivating
what do I do when I'm bored what do I do
when I'm you know just laying around or
in meetings or something like that
oh I doodle a lot I kind of draw and the
way I tend to draw is either spirals or
draw a box and then try to kind of color
it in and then I thought about
meditation of course the other big angle
there's kind of these zen gardens which
I guess is what I'm doing now you know
the the monks would do these gardens and
it's just a captivating task for them
when they're really just trying to learn
to be blank in their mind so I thought
okay well let's make a let's make a
spiral game here's the spiral and you
hover it
I can I can abolish it I can get it I
went too fast go to slow down nice and
centering whoa slow down I'm nervous in
front of everybody it's like live coding
but live spiralling that's an eSport of
the future
yeah let's give me that all right so
spyro is awesome I've got a second game
again wow this is really I'm enjoying it
I'm enjoying it let's do another one
let's let's keep going with this
nature is something you know you're out
for a walk you're out having fun nature
was a perfect inspiration for for this
this project and I thought yeah let's
make another game let's kind of keep
going with this here's a it's almost
like how things in the forest will will
rot away and they'll slowly break down
oh yeah this is doing it as well I can
go fast you know but it's not as
rewarding I'm gonna have to start
sitting down gonna have to start
concentrating to kind of hit all these
points off oh I'll do this one Oh at
least get all the big ones no I'm just
gonna do it all okay all right you get
the point and I thought oh this is kind
of great let me just wrap all these
games up let me put them in a bundle and
so that's exactly what I did I thought
I'll build out a little website I called
up the Zen zone registered domain put it
on there and yeah so that's it that's
the kind of Zen zone you can come in
pick a game that you want to do let's do
the swirl let's do it for three minutes
so you can kind of see when you do one
there will be a second one that will
kind of slide in and you get you get
kind of focused out on you'll get
enjoyment and this is exactly what I'm
talking about it's like oh here's
something that I've made from nothing
with random ideas that I've kind of just
picked up along the way
it kind of provides a little bit of use
it's super nice you know I'm stressing
out about the talk over here I can kind
of sit and focus myself away and and
build something just for fun and yeah so
that's the lesson it's kind of a just
wanted to demonstrate so much that you
can just kind of put things together and
not only that is I've kind of build this
whole platform you know I build a whole
website experience I played around with
react I made a bunch of different games
canvas in react is this whole whole
different thing
recursion for those those crushing bowls
the spiral it turns out is called an
alchemy daeun spiral and there's all
this kind of math behind it I just
messed things up put everything on
Amazon you know do all the domain it's
like oh this is a huge bundle of things
that I've had to learn and
just to get on that way and not only
that is I've kind of built a platform to
build other things you know if you have
more kind of weird meditation ideas or
anything like that I can just kind of
add them on a dam onto the side so
that's yeah that's kind of what I want
to just want to talk about I just
hopefully give everyone a little bit of
food food for thought there's my Twitter
my github I'll put the Zen zone is on
github but I'll just open source it
later today watch out for a tweet
there's my website you can kind of keep
track of my similar kind of musings and
creations thank you
[Applause]